We've discussed the big five traits,
extroversion,
that's sensitivity to positive emotion.
Neuroticism had sensitivity to negative
emotion,
not all negative emotions,
mostly fear anxiety and emotional pain
seemed to load on neuroticism,
disgust,
which is another negative emotion.
It seems to be more associated
with conscientiousness,
particularly its orderliness aspect,
agreeableness,
conscientiousness and openness.
We're going to talk about agreeableness
today.
Agreeableness is a very difficult
personality dimension to understand.
I think partly because it's difficult to
dissociate from neuroticism,
Andy and as well from extroversion
because agreeable people like you and so
that kind of sounds like extroversion
and disagreeable people sound like
they're hard to get along with and they
sort of are,
but people who were high in neuroticism
or hard to get along with too,
and they tend to be volatile and
irritable and so most of the time if
you're engaged in a contentious issue
with someone and emotions flare it,
it usually has more to do with trait
neuroticism then with disagreeableness
per se.
So what I'm going to do is try to
describe to you what the agreeable trait
is on both of its dimensions and also to
lay out the pros and cons of existence
on that normal distribution trait,
normal distribution at more or less
every point.
Because I think my,
the way I look at it anyways,
there's a bit of all of the traits.
Agreeableness is the one that seems to
come with the most market positive and
negative aspects.
Features let's say.
So we don't confuse it with aspects the
both positive and negative features at
each point on the distribution.
It's a very complex,
it seems to be a very,
very complex dimension.
So I'll read you some of the questions
from the big five aspect scale and
that'll give you kind of a initial,
a rule of thumb estimate about whether
or not you're agreeable or disagreeable.
And so here,
here are some of the questions,
uh,
imagine that you're answering these for
yourself on a scale from one to five,
strongly disagree to strongly agree.
So the first question is,
I'm not interested in other people's
problems.
So if you are interested in other
people's problems,
that tilts you towards agreeableness and
I believe that's a agreeableness is
divided into compassion and politeness,
which also sounded like very positive
things,
right?
Because everyone wants to be
compassionate to everyone,
wants to be polite and so you might say,
well,
is is that a virtue?
Are those virtues and with the other Ed
being actually negative to be not
compassionate,
not polite,
it's certainly worded that way and
that's actually a mistake because we
know that these traits are normally
distributed roughly speaking,
right,
and that that means that there has to be
positive and negative features at every
single position on the distribution and
sort of make the,
make the presupposition,
for example,
that being extroverted as being better
than it being introverted or that being
emotionally stable is necessarily better
than being neurotic,
is to make a kind of a kind of confusion
of of moral are what obligation with
trait which trait position.
You have to assume that there's
advantages and disadvantage also all the
way along or or the distribution
wouldn't have set itself up that way.
Especially because these seams seem to
be biologically instantiated traits.
So anyways,
um,
if you're interested in other people's
problems,
they like to.
Ember unburden themselves to you,
you care about it.
That's a mark of compassion.
If you're more or less indifferent to
other people's stupid problems and you
wish they just get on with it,
then you're less compassionate,
you're harsher and more and more,
um,
well,
at the extreme,
more Kelis ah,
let's see.
Respect.
Authority.
That's politeness.
That's part of agreeableness.
I'm rarely.
Let's see,
wow.
Feel others' emotions.
Compassion.
Inquire about others' wellbeing.
Compassion
can't be bothered with others' needs.
Take advantage of others that's
disagreeable.
Obviously.
Sympathize with others' feelings.
Avoid imposing my will on others.
Wait for others to lead the way.
Okay.
I think,
I think all of those were associated
with trait agreeableness or
disagreeableness.
So let's,
let's think about this for a minute.
So I'm going to tell you how I
conceptualize agreeableness.
The first thing you want to know is that
women are more agreeable than men,
about half a standard deviation,
and that's approximately enough so that
if you took a random mail in a random
female out of the population and you
tried to guess who was more agreeable
and you guessed the female,
you'd be right about 60 percent of the
time.
So and,
but what,
what,
what's interesting about that,
and this is something also to keep in
mind,
is about normal distributions.
You know,
so imagine you have normal distribution
so that most people are in the middle
and then you have another normal
distribution,
male and female,
and mostly they overlap,
but you see out here and out here,
they don't overlap at all.
And so even though on average men and
women don't just don't,
aren't that much different in terms of
their levels of agreeableness by the
group.
If you go out and you look at the
extremes,
they're very different.
So all of the most agreeable people are
women and all of the most disagreeable
people are men.
And the thing is,
the extremes are often what matter
rather than what's in the middle.
And so one of the ways that's reflected
in society by the way,
is there's way more men in prison and
the best personality predictor of being
in prison is to be low in agreeableness.
It makes you Kelis.
Now you may think,
well,
what's the opposite of compassion and
politeness?
And the answer to that is,
I think it's best sort of conceptualized
as a,
as a trading game.
So let's say that we're going to play
repeated trading games and if you're a
very agreeable then you're going to
bargain harder on my behalf than you're
going to bargain on your own behalf.
Whereas if you're very disagreeable,
you're going to do the reverse.
You're going to think,
I mean this trading game for me and you
are going to take care of your own
interests.
Were an agreeable person,
is going to say no,
no,
at best,
at worst,
this has to be 50 slash 50.
But I'd like to help you every way I
can.
Okay?
Now the credit.
Okay,
so you Kinda,
you kind of understand that now the
advantage to being agreeable then is
that you're good in teams and you're
very much likely to give other people
credit that bad.
The downside of being agreeable is that
you're not very good at putting forward
your own interests and so one of the
things that predicts salary across time,
for example is agreeableness and it
predicts it negatively and so it's part
of the reason why women get paid less
than men and this is something for the
women in the class who really listened
to because you how you get paid across
time depends on a very large number of
things.
Right?
It depends on your skills and your
abilities and your position and your
social network and all of that.
But the other thing it depends on is
whether or not you actually go ask for
money or maybe that you don't even ask
because actually you don't ask for
money.
You tell people that you need to be paid
more or something they don't like will
happen and I don't mean as a threat.
I mean that you have to be willing when
you're negotiating to have an
alternative,
you go talk to your boss who isn't going
to give you money because everyone wants
money,
right?
It's a competitive game.
You're going to have to be.
You're going to have to go there and
say,
look,
here's what I do.
Here's why it's useful.
Here's why you have to give me more
money and this is my opportunities.
If you don't,
and then you're not taking your boss's
money anyways because it's very seldom,
very frequently the case that he's
working for a whopping big company,
but he needs an excuse to give you money
because everyone's asking for money all
the time and so you have to put your
case forward powerfully and
disagreeable.
Now,
you don't want to do it to disagree,
I believe,
because then he's going to think that
you're a son of a bitch and maybe he's
not going to give you anything and maybe
you'll get fired for being mouthy and
all of that,
and that certainly happens to people who
are too disagreeable.
You got to get the balance right,
but it's definitely the case and the
other thing that happens to women that's
also worth noting,
and this is probably because they're
higher negative emotion,
is they tend to underestimate their own
utility in business settings,
right?
Because if you're trying to evaluate
what you're like and you're more tilted
towards negative emotion than the things
that you do that are wrong,
are going to stand out more,
more on the foreground and the things
that you do that are right.
So if you go into a negotiation and
you're uncertain already because you
have self doubts and then you're
agreeable in the negotiation,
what's going to happen is that you're
not going to win as often and winning in
a business setting or in their career
development setting means more
opportunity for promotion and more
revenue generated.
Now the downside of that of course,
is as you climb the business hierarchy
is that you also have to take on more
responsibility and that responsibility
is sometimes unpleasant as well.
Especially to people who are agreeable
because you're not necessarily liked if
you're in a position of authority and
agreeable people.
Really liked to be liked,
it's their primary motive motivator
because they're concerned about the
maintenance,
I would say,
of,
of intimate positive relationships,
and that also makes them conflict
avoidant.
Okay,
so now you guys can think about this,
but.
But I'll,
I'll tell you why.
I think the personality differences
between men and women exist now.
These are speculative hypotheses,
but they're reasonably well documented
by,
by the relevant literature.
So let's,
let's think about it.
The first thing we might think about is
what's the difference between men and
women?
Well,
how do they differ?
the first thing we might observe is that
if you look at personality differences
be between pre pubescent boys and girls.
They're not very large.
Boys and girls don't differ in terms of
their trait.
Neuroticism,
for example,
what happens is that when puberty kicks
in,
women's trait neuroticism rises and it
stays higher than men for the rest of
their life.
And this is why you see this reflected
in the different kinds of
psychopathology that be set.
The two sexes,
so men are overrepresented in
alcoholism,
drug abuse,
antisocial personality,
and a host of learning disorders.
As well as that attention deficit
disorder and women are overrepresented
in depression and anxiety primarily now
it seems to be tightly associated with
higher levels of trait neuroticism
because maybe it's if you're at the 95th
percentile or higher,
let's say in trait neuroticism,
there isn't much different than
difference between that and being
somewhat prone to depression and anxiety
and because the curves overlap,
you know the,
the,
the curves are identical.
The normal distributions are identical
for men and women.
You tilt the one to the,
to the right,
to the women's,
curved to the right towards higher
levels of the rotor system.
You go out and you look for the person
in 20 who has the highest levels of
negative emotion.
It's much more likely to be female than
male.
Okay,
so let's see if we can figure out why.
So we're going to tell you some things,
basic differences between men and women.
And you can tell me what you think about
it if you are,
if you agree or disagree.
Okay.
First size,
differential emergence between men and
women at puberty,
right?
Because boys and girls are roughly the
same size.
And roughly the same strength,
but men get bigger at puberty when the
testosterone kicks in,
and more importantly,
not only do they get taller and heavier,
but their upper body strength is much
higher,
and that's a real issue for for combat
because human beings punch.
There's other animals that do that.
Kangaroos do that two ways,
so we're not the.
We're not the only people that punch,
but we have clubs on the ends of our
arms and so that's how we defend
ourselves.
And so if you have a lot of upper body
strength,
especially short across the shoulders
and you're heavier than you can step the
punch and it's a lot more devastating.
Now it is the case that if you look at
the statistics for physical altercations
in marriage,
women attack their husbands more often.
The husbands attack their wives.
While you think that,
why is that?
Well,
let's assume that there isn't any reason
other than both.
People in a relationship can get upset
and the women know that if they hit
their husbands,
nothing's really going to happen,
right?
Because if you're a real,
you know,
if you're a woman about that high and
your husband is say,
my height,
you're,
unless you hit me with an object or
something that's sharp,
the probability that you're going to do
by any serious damage is pretty low.
You might hurt me,
but if I do the reverse and hit you and
I really hit you,
then I might kill you.
And so the reason at least one of the
reasons why women can be more physically
aggressive in minor ways in a
relationship is because everyone knows
the wife and the husband equally,
that the consequence of the physical
aggression is much more limited.
So men do more serious damage to women,
but women are more aggressive in
relationships.
So That's interesting.
So okay,
so there's a bar.
There is a body size difference that's
important to strength differential.
That's important.
Next thing I think.
So let's assume that the reason that
women are higher in sensitivity to
negative emotion is because the world is
actually more dangerous to women.
Right?
Because that would be the most logical
reason why there would be a sex
difference in a sex difference in it's
something like fear or sensitivity to
punishment.
Well first there's the danger of
physical altercation.
Second,
there's the sexual danger.
So women become sexually vulnerable at
puberty.
And why do I say vulnerable?
While it's straightforward,
it's because the cost of sex for women
is way higher than it is for men are
certainly has been throughout our
evolutionary history because if a man
has an unwanted sexual encounter while
then he walks away and maybe he's
persecuted by the state or prosecuted by
the state for it.
But if a woman has an unwanted,
unwarranted or incautious sexual
encounter and she ends up pregnant then,
well,
in traditional societies that's you're
just done.
And even in modern societies that are
rich,
like ours,
you're,
it's,
uh,
I don't have to go into that.
It's big trouble no matter what you do
about it.
It's big trouble.
So being,
being more nervous about.
That makes perfect sense.
But then here's the last thing.
And I think that women's nervous systems
are not adapted to women.
I think women's nervous systems are
adapted to the mother infant dyad and
because you are not the same creature
when you have an infant,
not at all,
you're way more vulnerable and it's
partly because you have to express their
vulnerability of the infant and you also
have to care for it.
Right?
So you think about an infant especially
under nine months,
so let's say how are you going to be
wired up if you're going to optimally
care for an infant under nine months,
and I'm saying under nine months because
women generally do the bulk of childcare
for infants who are under nine months
old and part of the reason for that.
There's a whole host of reasons,
but part of the reasons for that
obviously is that they breastfeed,
but imagine what you need to be wired up
biologically in order to care for an
infant.
First of all,
they're very demanding,
right?
Because they're completely helpless and
they're demanding 24 hours a day and
it's quite.
It's quite a.
it's quite an emotional load and an
infant under nine months is never wrong.
Right.
What you do to an infant under nine
months is when they're in distress,
you always respond,
you never tell the infant,
get your act together and stop whining.
Right?
Which you can do,
say to an end to a child that's 18
months old,
you can start having that sort of
conversation,
but under nine months it's like nothing
is the infant's fault.
It's surrounded in an extraordinarily
threatening world and you have to be
responsive to what it needs regardless
of what you want and you have to be very
sensitive to the threats that emerge in
the environment and so I think the price
that women pay for that ability to have
an intimate relationship with infants in
the very earliest stages of development
is that their nervous systems are
actually wired so that they can perform
that role optimally.
And the disadvantage to that is that
having a temperament like that doesn't
work that well when you're dealing with
adult men,
especially when you're dealing with them
and in a business environment because
it's not the same thing.
Not at all.
It's a competitive environment.
So,
okay,
so agreeable people are compassionate
and polite.
What are disagreeable people like?
They're tough minded,
they're blunt,
they're competitive,
and they won't do a damn thing they
don't want to do so it isn't exactly
that they're aggressive,
although they will push you the hell out
of their way if you're in the way
they're not.
They're not like volatile like you are
if you're high in neuroticism.
It isn't defensive aggression.
It's more like predatory aggression.
It's dominance behavior.
And so for someone who's high,
who's high,
highly disagreeable,
they look at the world as a place in
which they can compete and win.
And I'll tell you a story,
I have a friend.
I gave him my personality test,
the Big Five aspects scale that Colin de
young developed in my lab and
I knew he was a disagreeable guy.
And by interacting with them,
um,
I mean he's even rude to people sort of
spontaneously on the street.
I actually liked them quite a bit.
He's very,
very funny.
He's also very conscientious so you can
trust it,
but it's disagreeable as hell.
And uh,
so I gave him this test because I
thought it would be funny and he came
out as the most disagreeable person in
10,000,
so reasonably reasonable and
compassionate 30th percentile,
but like point zero,
zero,
one in politeness,
so he's extraordinarily blunt and he'll
just say absolutely anything,
no matter how horrible it is.
And he was often brought into
corporations to sort of clean them up.
So if a corporation was tilting and not
doing well,
they bring him into find out how the
useless people were in fire them.
And I talked to them about that because
I've had the opportunity to have to not
have graduate students in my lab for
example,
that weren't performing well.
And I find it very,
very difficult dress someone down and
certainly difficult to fire them.
I just hate it because I'm actually
quite agreeable person,
much to my chagrin.
And I asked him about that and I said,
well,
what do you do?
You have to fire people all the time.
How do you handle that?
He says,
handle it.
I enjoy it.
And I thought,
wow,
that's so interesting that someone would
have that response.
I said,
well,
what do you mean you enjoy it?
He said,
look,
I go into these companies and I analyze
the performance of groups of people.
Right?
And there's in those groups or people
who are really striving,
really trying hard and working
themselves really hard and being
productive.
And then there's these people that are
just doing nothing.
They're completely in the way.
They don't carry their weight at all.
They take advantage every chance they
get.
And they're always whining about why
they can't work.
It's like I find out who they are.
I called them into my office and I tell
them exactly what they've been doing.
It's like hit the road buddy.
You've had your had your run of it.
And I thought,
Oh yeah,
okay,
fair enough.
You know.
Well,
I can tell you,
you know,
I've had situations in my lab where I
had underperforming graduate students
and one of the things that was really
awful about that was that it was really
hard on the high performing graduate
students,
you know,
because they felt that even being in the
same category as the people who weren't
working hard and pulling their weight,
devalued what they were doing,
you know?
And that's exactly right.
And so this is also why there's,
there's a conscientiousness trait,
agreeableness trait.
Conscientious people judge you on your
accomplishments,
right?
They don't give a damn about your
feelings,
not a bit.
It's like are you doing the work or not?
Whereas agreeable people think,
well,
you know,
your mother is sick and you know,
you've,
you've got a bunch of family problems
and,
and we all have to take care of each
other and it's no wonder that you're
having a rough time and like you can't
say that one of those attitudes is
correct and the other isn't correct.
You can't say that there wouldn't be
those two dimensions if there wasn't
something correct about both of them,
but you can certainly point out that
often they conflict,
you know,
and so the demand for for inclusiveness
and unity and care and the demand for
high level performance in a hierarchical
structure.
They're very different orientations in
the world and so it's complicated for
people who are agreeable and
conscientious and actually I think often
that large corporations and large,
large institutions of any sort run on
the unheralded labor of people who are
high in agreeableness and high in
conscientiousness.
They're disproportionately women and my
experience in large institutions has
been that if you want to hire someone to
exploit appropriately,
no,
not appropriately.
If you want to hire someone to exploit
productively,
you higher middle aged women who are
hyper conscientious and who are
agreeable because they'll do everything.
They won't take credit for it and they
won't complain and that's nasty and I
think that happens all the time.
And so one of the things you have to be
careful of if you're agreeable,
is not to be exploited because you'll
lie not to be exploited.
And I think the reason for that is
because you're wired to be exploited by
infants.
And so that just doesn't work so well in
the actual world.
And one of the things,
one of the things that happens very
often in psychotherapy,
you know,
people come to psychotherapy for
multiple reasons,
but one of them is they often come
because they're too agreeable.
And so what they get is so called
assertiveness training.
Although it's not exactly assertiveness
that's being trained.
What it is is the ability to learn how
to negotiate on your own behalf.
And one of the things I tell agreeable
people,
especially if they're conscientious,
is
say what you think,
tell the truth about what you think
there's going to be things you think
that you think are nasty and harsh,
and they probably are nasty and harsh,
but they're also probably true.
And you need to bring those up to the
forefront and deliver the message.
And it's not straightforward at all
because agreeable people do not like
conflict,
not at all.
They smoothed the water,
you know when you can see,
you can see why that is in accordance
with the hypothesis that I'd been
putting forward.
You don't want conflict around infants.
It's too damn dangerous.
You don't want fights to break out.
You don't want anything to disturb the
relative peace you know,
and if you're also more prone to being
hurt physically and perhaps emotionally,
you also may be loath to engage in the
kind of high intensity conflict that
will solve problems in the short term
because the law to conflict,
it takes a lot of conflict,
is solve problems in the short term and
you know if that can spiral up to where
it's dangerous,
which it can,
if it gets uncontrolled,
it might be safer in the short term to
keep the waters smooth and to not delve
into those situations where conflict
emerges.
The problem with that is it's not a very
good medium to longterm strategy,
right?
Because lots,
lots of times there are things you have
to talk about because they're not gonna
go away and so partly what you do with
agreeable people as you get them to
figure out and they have a hard time
with this too.
If you ask a disagreeable person what
what he wants say or she wants,
they'll tell you right away,
they know it's like,
this is what I want and this is how I'm
to get it,
but an agreeable people,
especially if they're really agreeable,
are so agreeable that they often don't
even know what they want because they're
so accustomed to living for other people
and to finding out what other people
want and to try and make them
comfortable and so forth.
That it's harder for them to find a
sense of their own desires as they move
through life.
And that's not.
But there's situations where that's
advantageous,
but it's certainly not advantageous if
you're going to try to a,
forged yourself a career that just
doesn't work at all.
So.
Alright.
What else do I want to tell you about
agreeableness?
Well,
I could tell you a little bit about the.
The regulation of aggression when one of
the things I studied,
especially when I was in Montreal,
was the development of antisocial
behavior in children and in and in a and
in adolescence and antisocial children,
so they tend to be aggressive,
antisocial children tend to turn into
antisocial conduct disorder.
Technically speaking,
conduct disordered children tend to turn
into conduct disordered adolescents and
then they tend to turn into antisocial
and criminal adults.
And so I can tell you a little bit about
how that progresses.
I think because it's quite interesting
and it isn't what people generally
think.
So the first thing is if you want to be
criminal,
the best way to do it is to be really
low in agreeableness and really low in
conscientiousness.
Low in agreeableness means things are
for me and not for you,
and you're not going to get me to do a
damn thing that I don't want to do and
I'll stand my ground and low in
conscientiousness means you can do all
the work and all sit back and take the
benefits.
And so if you have someone who's really
disagreeable and really unconscientious,
you have someone who's starting to
border on psychopath,
and if you add high intelligence and
high emotional stability to that,
then you have someone who won't work but
will reap the benefits.
Who doesn't give a damn about you?
Who is assertive as Helen who's smart
and a person like that's also going to
be charismatic because extroverted
disagreeable people are kind of
narcissistic but there.
But they'll,
they'll put themselves forward strongly
and if they don't show any signs of
fear,
that also indicates that they're
confident and it's easy for people to
confuse that with competence.
And that's how psychopaths get away with
what they're doing.
Although they have to move from person
to person because their religion,
their reputation will track.
So anyways,
back to the development of aggression in
children in the development of
criminality and adults.
Here's how it seems to work,
at least in part,
it's more complicated than this,
but I'll put in some of the sociological
elements as well.
So if you take children and you group
them together in age,
age eight in groups defined by age,
so let's say a 32 year olds,
33 year olds,
34 year olds,
all the way up to 18th,
and then you watch them interact and you
cold their behavior for kicking,
biting,
fighting,
and property theft.
Then what you'll find is that the two
year olds are by far the most aggressive
of the lot.
So that's pretty interesting.
You know,
because you think,
well,
children are naturally peaceful and if
they are aggressive it's because they
learn it.
It's like,
no,
that's true for a small minority of
children.
But there's a substantial number of
children who are aggressive at two by
nature.
Most of them are male.
Now that doesn't mean most children are
like that because they're not.
Even if you look at two year olds who
are the most aggressive human beings,
most two year olds aren't aggressive,
but some of them are and most of those
are male.
Okay?
So then let's say you identify this
cohort of aggressive two year olds and
you track them across time,
track them for the next two to four
years or the next track them until
they're four years old.
What you find is the vast majority of
the hyper aggressive male till year olds
get socialized perfectly well.
So by the time they're four,
they're temperamentally probably still
more aggressive,
but they've become civilized little
monsters so other people can tolerate
them and that means that they've had
parents or peers or educational
experiences that enabled them to learn
how to interact productively with other
kids and to bring their aggressive
nature under control.
Some of that seems to be mediated by the
opportunity to engage in rough and
tumble play and that's one of the things
that we know that that helps socialize.
Rats,
for example.
It's vital to them,
but it also seems to really be good for
socializing young kids and rough and
tumble play,
which is something that adult males
particularly like to do with young kids.
By the way,
not not before nine months because
they're just too little,
but once they become ambulatory and you
know,
kind of poppy like,
so that they're a little bit more robust
than you can play a lot with them and
you can play with them right at the edge
of danger to which kids.
Absolutely.
They absolutely go nuts for that.
They love that.
So when,
when I had little kids,
I made this kind of wrestling ring out
of these two couches that we had that
would hook together and I'd bring them
on there and toss them up in the air and
catch them,
you know,
eight,
10 feet.
No,
no,
no.
A foot in the air and catch them and
they go like this and then,
you know,
I catch them and they'd laugh and I'd
throw them up and they're all freaked
out and then they'd laugh and you know,
so they're learning trust with that in
an embodied way.
And they're also learning.
And this is from stretching them out and
wrestling them and twisting them around
and letting them pull on your hair and
hit you.
And all of those things,
they learn deep in their bones,
exactly what can hurt them and what
doesn't in the.
You want to kind of push them to the
edge so that they can tell the
difference between what hurts and what
still within the realm of the game.
And you do the same thing when they're
wrestling with you.
So they learn not to awkwardly stick
their thumb in your eye or,
or,
or do things that are actually painful.
Like grab your lip and pull it,
you know,
it's like,
no,
you let go of my lip,
you know.
And so that seems to help regulate the
aggressive impulses in and help the
church child find a more appropriate
embodiment.
You could think that what you're doing
in some sense when you're rough and
tumble playing with kids is teaching
them how to dance because that is what
you're doing.
You know,
you're making them comfortable in their
bodies,
in all of its extension and building in
that kind of body fluency that you see
in people who are well situated inside
themselves.
And so that's something to really think
about.
You know?
And it's,
it's appalling.
We know that the ability to engage in
rough and tumble play among rats
inhibits aggression,
impulsive,
aggressive aggression among rats.
We also know that if you deprive rats,
have the ability to have the opportunity
to engage in rough and tumble play,
they,
they show prefrontal cortical
developmental deficits and manifest
behaviors that are akin to attention
deficit disorder,
which you can then treat with Ritalin.
And so one of the things that's
happening with boys because they're way
more dosed with attention deficit
disorder medication than girls,
is that there are natural proclivity to
engage in robust and troublesome.
Active play isn't appropriate for a
school environment where you're just
supposed to sit down and shut up.
And so the kids get hyperactive and
instead of letting them out to run
around until they fall over half
exhausted,
which is exactly what you should do,
you know,
you medicate them.
So that are exploratory systems which
are,
um,
the,
the activity of which is facilitated by
by the dual pub anergic agonist.
That's the adhd medication,
suppresses the play function.
It's absolutely appalling.
There's no excuse for it,
you know,
and,
but it,
it's a good,
it's a good indictment of the education
system because why in the world would
you take six year old kids and get them
to sit without moving for five hours
unless you want them to grow up fat and
stupid?
Why in the world would you train them to
do that?
Well,
it's easier.
That's one thing you know,
and,
and when they're sitting there,
there's nothing disruptive about the
rough and tumble play and that can be
quite,
you know,
play can be quite disruptive.
So anyways,
most of these kids are reasonably well
socialized by the time they're the age
of four music,
one mechanism or another,
they learn how to regulate their
aggression and they learn how to engage
in fictional play structures with other
kids.
They learn how to cooperate and compete
and the advantage to having a well
socialized disagreeable person is that
they really don't let much get in their
way.
So if you can get a kid who's
disagreeable,
socialized,
that person can be quite quite the
creature,
you know,
because they're very,
they're very forward moving in their
nature and very difficult to stop.
But if you don't get them successfully
domesticated,
tamed,
roughly speaking by the time they're for
their peers,
reject them,
and that's a big problem because your
job as a parent is to make your child
socially desirable by the age of four.
I got it.
You want to burn that into your brain
because people don't know that that's
your job.
And here's,
here's why.
If you think it's easy,
if you think about it carefully,
so you imagine you've got a.
you've got a three year old child,
so it's sort of halfway through that
initial period of socialization and you
take that child out in public,
okay,
what do you want for the Child?
Who Cares about you?
What do you want from the child,
for the Child?
You want the child to be able to
interact with other children and adults
so that the children are welcoming and
smile and wanting to play with him or
her.
And so the adults are happy to see the
child and treat him or her properly,
and if your child's a horrible little
monster because you're afraid of
disciplining them or you don't know how
to do that properly,
then what they're going to do is they're
going to experience nothing but
rejection from other children and false
smiles from other parents and adults.
And that's so.
Then you're throwing the child out there
into a world where every single face
that they see is either hostile or lying
and that's not something that's going to
be particularly conducive to the mental
health or the wellbeing of your child.
If your child can learn a couple simple
rules of behavior,
like don't interrupt adults when they're
talking too much and pay attention and
try not to hit the other kids over the
head with the truck anymore than is
absolutely necessary then and you know,
and share and play properly.
Then when they meet other kids,
the kids are going to try out a few
little play routines on them and that's
going to go well and then they're going
to go off and socialize each other for
the rest of their lives because that's
what happens is that from four years old
onwards,
the primary socialization with children
takes place among other children and so
if the kids don't get in on that early,
they don't move into that developmental
spiral upwards and they're left behind
and you can imagine how terrible that is
because a four year old will not play
with another four year old who's too,
but a five year old certainly will not
play with a five year old who's too
right,
because the gap is just starting to get
unbelievably large and so the kids start
out behind and then the peers leave that
behind and then those kids are alienated
and outside the Peer Group for the rest
of their life.
Those are the ones that grow up to be
longterm antisocial,
right?
They're already aggressive.
It doesn't dip down.
Now what happens to normal boys,
roughly speaking,
imagine the aggressive two-year-old
types.
It gets socialized so their level of
aggression goes down and then they hit
puberty and testosterone kicks in and
bang,
levels of aggression go back up,
and so that's why males are criminals
between the ages roughly of 16 and about
25.
So when it matches the creativity curve,
by the way,
it's so cool.
If you look at the spike of creativity
among men,
16 to 25 and it starts to go down,
criminality matches that absolutely
perfectly.
So that's quite cool.
So and part of so the testosterone
levels raise the average level of
aggression among men.
It's more dominance than aggression.
Actually,
testosterone is by no means all bad and
then it starts to decrease at about age
25 or 26,
which is usually with men.
Stop staying up late at night,
stopped drinking as much,
develop a full time career and take on
the burdens and responsibilities and
opportunities that are associated with a
longterm partner and family.
And so while.
So that's,
that's the development of,
of,
of what would I would I would call
predatory aggression because I also
think that the,
the agreeableness distribution is
probably something like predatory
aggression versus maternal sympathy.
It's something like that.
So if you look at other,
if you look at other mammals that are,
that are predators,
because we're predators as well as prey
animals.
If you look at other animals like bears,
the male bear has absolutely nothing to
do with the raising of the infants.
In fact,
the female bears will keep the mail the
hell away because he's likely to kill
the infants and maybe even to eat them.
So there's no matter analogy at all in
solitary male mammalian predators.
Now it depends on how social they are,
but roughly speaking,
that's the situation.
Whereas with human beings,
males are quite maternal.
So.
But anyways,
I think the,
the extreme of agreeableness on the low
end,
so disagreeableness is predation and the
extreme on the upper end is maternal
caring.
And so,
and those two things compete,
right?
Obviously it's very difficult to be both
of those at the same time.
And so men,
of course,
in the wild,
so to speak,
are very,
very few women hunt in modern societies
or an or an archaic societies and you
can also understand why that is because
hunting actually requires hurting
something,
killing it,
and it's usually something that's not
very impressed about being hurt or
killed in that will emit a lot of
distress while it's happening.
And so for anybody who's compassionate,
who's,
who's got compassionate,
you know,
one of the fundamental elements of their
temperament,
that's something they're just not going
to be able to tolerate at all.
So there's,
you know,
in the evolutionary landscape because
that's really what we're talking about.
There's tension behind the development
of different modes of being in the
world.
And if you're good at one thing,
that sometimes means that you can't be
good at the other thing at the same
time.
So I was going to have a guest speaker
for you last week,
but the person I had invited in had some
familial troubles.
So that didn't work out.
But she's a graduate student of mine and
one of the things that we'd been working
on in my lab,
generally speaking,
is the delineation of the relationship
between personality traits and political
belief.
Until I've told you a little bit about
the things that distinguished liberals
from conservatives,
right?
The Conservatives are high in
conscientiousness,
especially orderliness and low in trait
openness.
And so that means a conservative,
someone who puts things in boxes,
puts the boxes in order and doesn't like
them to be messed up.
Right?
So they liked the borders between things
to remain determinant.
And,
and,
and uh,
what would you say an inviolable.
And I think that's true at every level
from the conceptual all the way up to
the political.
I think that the fundamental political
question,
and I think this is why the temperaments
align across these political dimensions,
is whether the borders between things
should be open or closed.
You see this reflected it worldwide
right now in the arguments about
immigration,
right?
Because the liberal types of saying open
the gates and the Conservatives are
saying,
wait,
you don't know what you're inviting in.
And you might say,
well,
who's right?
And the answer is you don't know.
That's the thing,
because sometimes the right answer is
open the gates.
These are interesting people.
We could trade with them,
we could learn from each other,
and sometimes the answer is don't
bother.
What's going to come in is going to wipe
you out and kill you and really do it.
I mean,
so here's an example dot why I think
orderliness is associated with disgust
sensitivity,
and it's one of the determining factors
of conservative political belief.
What happened when the Europeans came to
North America?
What happened when the Spaniards came to
Ninety five percent of the native
Americans died.
Why?
Because the Spaniards brought illness,
smallpox,
measles,
chicken pox,
all of these things that the native
Americans had absolutely no resistance
through.
There were hardly any diseases at all.
In north and South America,
the Spaniards showed up within 50 to 100
years.
Nineteen out of 20 of the native
Americans were dead.
You never know what people are bringing
with them.
And so what that means is that how
should you respond to people who are
outside of your circle of familiarity or
the answer is one,
they might kill you in all sorts of ways
to,
they might bring with them things to
trade their of inestimable value.
So you're stuck.
It's like,
how the hell are you going to reconcile
that problem?
And the answer is,
well,
we reconcile at temperamentally roughly
speaking.
So half the people are temperamentally
wired up to say,
no,
let's keep the damn box is closed.
Took a long time to pack everything in
there and to get it into order.
And the liberals say,
well wait a minute,
you don't know if you've got things in
the right boxes to begin with.
The things that you're keeping in the
end are getting stale and old and maybe
we need some new ideas and new people to
rejuvenate the situation.
It's like that's political discussion
and that political discussion has to
proceed because there's no way of
solving that problem except by
discussing it so well.
How does that relate to agreeableness?
We also looked at political correctness
and so here's an interesting thing
purely from a scientific perspective.
You might ask yourself,
if you talk about political correctness,
one of the things that the people who
tend to be labeled as political
politically correct say is there's no
such thing as political correctness.
It's just a pejorative label that people
who are impo opposed to those views
impose on a set of beliefs to demonize
it perfectly reasonable objection and
you'd never know it might be true,
but the thing is psychometrically.
You can solve that problem and you solve
it the same way that you solve the
problem of what constitutes human
personality.
So this is the way we tried to solve it
and you can think about methodologically
because that's how you should think
about it.
The first thing we did was collect a
very large number of statements from
press accounts.
That seemed to indicate what people
generally refer to as political
correctness.
So we had a small team of people combing
media reports to come out with opinions
or attitudes that looked like they were
characteristic of the.
Of the differentiation between
politically correct people and people
who aren't politically correct,
so we've got about 400 statements like
that and what you want to do is you
imagine that,
that there is a core set of beliefs and
statements that people are defining in a
particular way and you're trying to get
a handle on what that is and even if it
exists,
what you do is over sample it.
If you can find questions that might
even tangentially be related to the
phenomena in,
in,
in question,
you include those because the statistics
will take care of the excess.
Okay,
so then what you do is you take your 400
items roughly speaking,
and you get people to register the
degree to which they agree or disagree
with them.
Get a thousand people to do that and
then you subject that to a factor
analysis.
And what the factor analysis does is
tell you how those questions clump.
Now they might not clump.
So for example,
you could do a factor analysis of a set
of questions and you can find that there
are 200 factors.
Let's let's say at $400.
There's 200 factors and none of them.
There's no big set of questions that are
clumping together.
Then you say,
well,
there's no evidence here that there is a
single underlying phenomena that unifies
those questions that you could
reasonably characterized with a name.
While that isn't what we found,
we found that there were two dimensions
of political correctness.
One of them looked like liberalism,
except that the people who were
politically correct,
in addition to being liberal,
we're very high in trait.
Agreeableness
and agreeableness has almost nothing to
do with the classic liberal conservative
divide.
It's weakly related in that
conservatives are more compassionate
than liberals.
Sorry.
Liberals are more compassionate than
conservatives.
They difference isn't huge and
conservatives are more polite than
liberals and the difference isn't huge.
So those are the two aspects of
agreeableness.
If you put them together,
they cancel each other out,
and so on.
Average conservatives and liberals don't
differ in agreeableness,
but polit politically political
correctness did clump together into two
categories.
Pc Liberalism,
we called it and pc authoritarianism.
The PC liberals were high in openness,
high in verbal intelligence and high in
agreeableness.
And the second group was Pc
Authoritarians,
and they were also high in
agreeableness,
but they were high in orderliness and
the correlation with that was negative
in relationship to verbal intelligence.
So we found that there were two
categories of political correctness that
it does in fact exist,
but that it's a very unstable construct
because factor one,
which was pc liberalism and factor two,
which was pc authoritarianism.
We're only correlated at point one.
And so what it indicates,
and this is our prediction,
roughly speaking from the lab,
is to the degree that there's unity,
so to speak,
on the politically correct left,
it'll fragment into two groups.
One will be the PC liberals and the
other will be the PC authoritarians.
Because although they're united by their
tendency to agreeableness,
they're not united by other
temperamental traits nor in their core
beliefs.
It's the PC authoritarian types.
For example,
we're very obsessed with language
control.
So,
and it's funny that it's agreeableness.
I've really been thinking about that.
And the what you know,
again,
this is a hypothesis and development,
but I think what's happening is that,
you know,
you're,
your temperamental proclivity allows you
to lay out a kind of radical
simplification on the world.
That's part of the advantage of having a
temperament.
So if you're a conscientious person in
the world is a place to go out there and
work.
If you're an open person in the world is
a place to go out there and discover new
ideas and do artistic things.
And if you're an agreeable person,
the world's a place to go out there and
establish intimate relationships.
And so they're,
they're simplifying
perspectives,
their edit and simplifying
personalities.
They're there or the manner in which
you're adapted to a particular niche.
I think what you see in agreeableness in
relationship to political belief is a
proclivity for people to divide the
world into defenseless infants and
predatory oppressors and that that's
blasted forward onto the political
landscape and things are conceptualized
along that temperamental variable.
So anyways,
that's,
we're at with regards to the analysis of
political belief.
So while we've got three minutes left,
and I'm wondering if anybody has a
particularly intelligent question or
failing,
not any question at all because I told
you a lot of things that are,
I would say contentious,
but I also think they're very much worth
knowing.
So I'm.
Yes.
You say the
high in agreeableness,
mother infant.
That's what it looks like to me.
Yeah.
Put projected onto the world period.
What would you say is the best way to go
about
knowing that we have the simplified
world.
It's really useful to investigate the
viewpoints of people who have opposing
views to yours because they'll tell you
things.
Not only will they tell you things you
don't know,
they'll also tell you how to see the
world in ways that you don't see it.
And they'll also have skills that you
don't have that you could develop.
So for example,
if you're an introverted person,
it's very useful to watch an extroverted
person because the extroverted person
has ways of being in the social world
that aren't natural to you,
that you can use this to improve your
toolkit.
And if you're disagreeable.
One of the best things to do with
disagreeable people,
especially if that's alienating them
from other people,
for example,
because it can,
you know,
people treat you like you're a selfish,
arrogant son of a bitch and maybe that's
because you are.
It's like,
okay,
so what do you do about that?
One of the,
one of the most promising treatments,
let's say for that is get the person to
do something for someone else once a day
just as a practice and learn how to do
it.
Maybe you can wake the circuit up,
you know,
if you think that it's lying dormant in
you,
which is probably right.
You know,
I think we have a very wide range of
propensity is within us.
Some are switched on,
genetic propensity,
summer switched on,
but I think that if you put yourself in
the right situation or walk yourself
through the right exercises,
you can switch some of these other
things on as well.
But it takes work and dedication and
discipline to do it
proactively
for personnel.
Yes.
Well,
I would say generally speaking,
if you want to adapt yourself properly
to life,
you should find a niche in the
environment that corresponds with your
temperament,
right?
You shouldn't work at cross purposes to
your temperament because it's just too
damn difficult.
But having done that,
then you should work on developing the
skills and viewpoints that exist in the
space opposite to your personality
because that's where you're
fundamentally underdeveloped.
That way I think you could extend out
your temperamental capability across a
wider range.
And to me that's roughly equivalent as
bringing a richer tool kit to each
situation.
You know,
so if you're hyper extroverted,
you should probably learn to shut up at
parties now and then and listen just to
see what's going on,
to see if you can manage it,
you know,
and if you're introverted,
well then you should learn how to speak
in public and to,
and to learn how to go to parties
without hiding in the corner and saying
nothing to anyone.
No.
And if you're agreeable,
then you need to learn how to be
disagreeable so people can't push you
around.
And if you're disagreeable,
you learn,
you need to learn how to be agreeable so
that you're not an evil son of a bitch,
you know,
so,
and the same thing applies even in the
conscientious domain.
It's like if you're too conscientious,
you need to learn to relax and let go a
little bit.
And if you're unconscientious it's time
like get out the Google calendar man,
and start scheduling your day,
right?
And beat yourself on the back of the
head with a stick until you're
disciplined enough so that you can
actually stick to something for some
length of time and not living in
absolute squalor,
which is something that would
characterize someone who's very
disorderly,
for example,
because they just,
they don't notice it doesn't bother
them.
Disorder.
It's like maybe they can see it,
but it doesn't have any emotional
valence.
And so it doesn't have any motivational
significance.
Now.
So the other thing you might want to
think about too,
if you're choosing a partner is try not
to choose someone who's too distant from
you on the temperamental variables
because you're going to have a hard time
bridging the gap.
You know,
it's hard for an introverted person and
an extroverted person to coexist and
it's really hard for an orderly person
and a disorderly person to coexist
because they will drive each other nuts.
Why don't you pick up?
Why are you so obsessed by it?
That's the basic argument,
you know,
so.
So it's useful to know about your
temperament so that you can negotiate
the space with your partner to wet as
well and I don't think you should try to
find someone who is exactly the same as
you because then you don't have the
benefits of the alternative viewpoint,
but you got to watch it because you may
hit eric and sizable differences of
various sorts and I've seen that most
particularly among couples who are high
and low in openness.
That's a rough one and also high and low
in conscientiousness.
That's another rough one because they
just cannot see how the other person
sees the world at at all.
Okay.
We'll see you on Tuesday.